through me you know I've never been
entirely sure except i wrote for the
love them Johnny and Jack and Merv and
others and my highest ambition was to be
a guest if I mean I could get the point
where I could be the one thing now
here's our here's our friend Dick Cavett
who's been on before but ABC had a pilot
of five half hours called the star and
the story and they got Van Johnson and
told part of his life each of these five
episodes and submitted this as a pilot
and they hated the show but they liked
the young man who hosted it that was
myself and so they thought let's try him
in a daytime talk format and it did and
that became a nighttime talk show format
job and that's why I say when you're
smiling oh there's a stand-up comic on
your staff and knows that many crap
comics would have no opening or closing
further acts come out singing when
you're smiling and then the end with
what she so bowlegged when she sits
around the house she sits around the
house and that's why I say when you're
smiling and gets off I'm sorry you
didn't need that did you
well I I had to fight the intellectual
label when i started in television
because first of all it's not going to
help your help your commercially and and
also it wasn't particularly true of me
I've ever thought of anybody thought I
was an intellectual I probably had never
really seen one maybe because I didn't
know any better than to think he was
supposed to read the guest books before
you had them on but I remember plowing
through 400 page books to have a guest
on for 15 minutes or less and somebody
pointed out you know you didn't use all
that homework and you don't need it I'm
intelligent but I'm not only
intellectual and I may have because I
was in the Ivy League I might have had a
better liberal arts education than a lot
of people but but I I I don't think of
myself as extraordinarily intelligent or
intellectual just reasonably so
clever joke set up mechanical up if you
deliver them southern mechanical you're
in the wrong business you're you're born
with what it is to make a comic and if
you don't have a good ear and you don't
have an instinctual way to save the line
and I mean an instinctive way to say the
line I guess an intellectual would have
gotten the word right I am I don't know
it's just nobody can learn it there have
been shysters who have been con artists
who have two had comedy schools where
they teach you how to deliver a punch
line and you know something but that
that's preying on the untalented and
taking their money if you're good you'll
do it right in your magic
it's horrible to try to write jokes for
yourself unless you're just writing
jokes but if you're trying to I thought
it'd be easy because I wrote for people
and I thought why don't I just write for
myself and then you're faced with Who am
I on stage as a comic I'm not the guy
with the enormous comedy nose or the big
feet or the red posture or whatever a
physical comic has certain things
Durante's nose loans old granny had a
lot more than a no is he had a fabulous
personality that came right out and got
you in the audience you'll have to put
an asterisk for your younger viewers as
to who Durant he was I don't have time
to tell them and I just the whole thing
is inborn really those who are destined
to make it were born with it and
probably will unless they have bad
breaks or alcoholism or nervous
breakdowns and the pressures of being in
show business but
well let me attack one word in your
question and it will include the best
advice I ever got what I was about to do
a talk show my great the great legendary
boss of mine Jack Paar to me the most
electric exciting neurotic strange
thrilling personality ever to appear on
television he had finished by then and I
was about to do a show and he said he
called up and he said kid let me give
you some advice oh there's my stammer
back he said but anyway forget it don't
do interviews interviews are clipboard
and Q&A and David Frost and crap like
that just don't do interviews make it a
conversation there is the secret now
it's all right for press people to do
interviews because they want to get the
10 facts and so forth but I've just
written wrote something about this and I
was thinking you could do an entire show
following Jack's advice without ever
that dreadful phrase let me ask you this
which seems to be required of everyone
on CNN MSNBC and almost everywhere else
whenever they say let me ask you this I
want to yell who is stopping you just
ask
you